ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
TWELVE PORGES BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHAIN DALLY DODD TO
ROSS SO GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWS HERTZBERG HILL
WEST SO- TADO JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING
MORE LOCK MORALE NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN I'M BURKE WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WILK. COLLEAGUES TO A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LEADING
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR%
FLAG BY OUR PRO TEM SENATOR
TONI ATKINS. LET US REMEMBER
THOSE REAR ALWAYS IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. AS WE CELEBRATE
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY THIS
WEEKEND LET US PRAY AND
GRATITUDE FOR ALL THOSE WORKING
TIRELESSLY FOR GENDER EQUALITY
IN OUR WORLD. GRACIOUS AND
MERCIFUL GOD FOR THOSE WHO
ACCOMPANIED THE VULNERABLE AND
DEPRESSED ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
WERE TRAFFICKED MAY THEY NOT BE
DISCOURAGED. FOR THOSE WHO SEEK
AN END TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
ABUSE MAY THEY SHOW US HOW TO
LOVE. WE PRAY FOR ALL WOMEN
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET IN
A WORLD OF PLENTY. MAY THEIR
EXPERIENCE JUSTICE AND MERCY.
FOR WOMEN EXPERIENCING THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE MAY
THEIR EXPERIENCE RELIEF THROUGH
WORLDWIDE COOPERATION. AND FOR
WOMEN WHOSE TALENTS AND
CREATIVITY GO UNNOTICED MAY
THEY KNOW THEIR OWN VALUE AND
WORTH. GRACIOUS GOD GIVE US
EYES TO SEE THE VALUE OF MAKING
THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE FOR
ALL GENDERS. GIVE US THE
STRENGTH TO OVERCOME OUR
INGRAINED PREJUDICES THAT HAVE
NO BASIS IN REALITY. WE ASK
THIS IN YOUR NAME A MAN.
pJOIN ME IN A SALUTE TO OUR
NATION'S FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES. ONE ZERO FOR
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY. AND FOR ALL. THANK YOU
SISTER FOR THOSE ELOQUENT
REMARKS. UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR COLLEAGUES UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
GALGIANI IT IS MY PRIVILEGE TO
INTRODUCE MIKE HOGAN WHO WAS IN
THE GALLERY MISTER HOGAN IS AN
AREA SALES MANAGER WITH
BERINGER INGELHEIM
PHARMACEUTICALS. IS HE HERE. IN
THE GALLERY IF WE COULD ALL. IF
YOU WOULD STAND PLEASE DON'T BE
SHY AND. HE ARE RECEIVED THE
ALLIED MEMBER OF THE YEAR AWARD
IN TWENTY NINETEEN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA POULTRY FEDERATION
CENTER GALGIANI COULD NOT BE
HERE BUT OUSTED WE RECOGNIZE
HIM AND SO IF YOU COULD JOIN ME
IN A ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR HER
GUEST. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. AND AS
A MATTER OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE ONE
OF MY DEAREST HIGH SCHOOL
FRIENDS. SO IF ANY OF YOU COUNT
YOU KNOW THAT'S FROM QUITE
AWHILE AGO HE IS HERE WITH HIS
WIFE NEVIL FRANKEL AND MARLENE
KNOWS BOMB WELCOME TO THE
SENATE CHAMBER. SENATOR ATKINS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
WELCOME THE FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER NETWORK IN NAY OR-
COMING IN AS I MAKE MY COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND RAPE NEED
A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN RECEIVE
COORDINATED WRAPAROUND SERVICES
IN ONE LOCATION FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS PROVIDE THAT. THE
CENTERS BRING TOGETHER POLICE
OFFICERS PROSECUTORS ADVOCATES
DOCTORS NURSES MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS CHAPLAINS AND
OTHER PROFESSIONALS UNDER ONE
ROOF TO PROVIDE TRAUMA INFORMED
SERVICES TO MORE THAN SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND ADULTS AND
CHILDREN OUR CHILD TRAUMA
SURVIVORS EACH YEAR SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND. AND I CAN SAY WITH
GREAT PRIDE THAT THE FIRST
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER WAS
CREATED IN SAN DIEGO IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO I WAS ON THE
CITY COUNCIL THEN AND WE
SUPPORTED IT STRONGLY ME AND OF
COURSE MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO. AS A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE I ALSO WAS ABLE TO
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN THAT ENSURE THAT
HELPING VICTIMS WHAT'S THE
FIRST PRIORITY OF FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTERS. BY DEFINING
THEM AS A MULTI AGENCY MULTI
DISCIPLINARY SERVICE CENTER
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO DEFINE
THOSE THINGS IN LAW AND STATURE
IT SO THAT THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS THAT COME ALONG WITH
THAT AND A RECOGNITION FOR
FUNDING SO. IT WAS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THAT MAY SOUND-
IT WAS IMPORTANT ALSO BECAUSE
HAVING ONE LOCATION A REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF TIMES THAT
VICTIMS HAD TO TELL THEIR STORY.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PLACES
THAT VICTIMS HAD TO GO FOR
HELP. AND INCREASED ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND SUPPORT FOR
VICTIMS AND THEIR CHILDREN. AND
TODAY THE FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS ARE REPRESENTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER NETWORK. THE NETWORK
SEEKS TO PROVIDE TRAINING
STATEWIDE COORDINATION OF
SERVICES FOR TRANSIENT VICTIMS
PROMOTION OF- PROMISING AND
BEST PRACTICES. AND ADVOCACY
FOR SURVIVOR SERVICES AND
SUPPORT. SO WITH ME TODAY- RKC
FORMER CITY ATTORNEY OF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO THE PRESIDENT
OF THE FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER
NETWORK. PRE A PAT PATEL THE
POLICY ANALYST AND PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER NETWORK AND SOME
OUR STATE- MY OWN DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SUMMER STEPHAN. DA
DIANA ACTON THE A NANCY
O'MALLEY AND D. A VERB OR
SALAZAR AND WE HAVE A WHOLE
GROUP OF PEOPLE ALSO IN THE
GALLERY. TO SUPPORT THIS DAY SO
WE'RE GOING TO PRESENT
RESOLUTION BUT COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING THE FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER. IN A WARM
SENATE THANK YOU FOR THE GREAT
WORK YOU'RE DOING.
AGAIN
WELCOME TO THE SENATE CHAMBER
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
OUTSTANDING WORK. CAN IT IS I
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
COLLEAGUES MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR MARCH SECOND
THROUGH MARCH FIFTH TWENTY
TWENTY. WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
ANY OTHER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES SEEING NONE WE WILL
MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS FILE ITEM ONE
SENATOR WILK. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF WILLIAM
PRESIDES FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT BOARD MALIK'S EXCUSE
ME COULD WE HAVE QUIET HERE SO
WE CAN PROCEED WITH THE DAILY
BUSINESS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MR PERSON ON IS A
PARTNER AT PRESIDING MOLOCH IN
ALSO A STRATEGIC ADVISOR FOR SB
INVESTMENT PARTNERS LLC HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH ON
ANIMUS. THANK OUT TENER WILL
FADE OR DO ON THE I'D SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SIR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS AYE BATES HI. FIVE
FORGES HI BRADFORD. HI
CABALLERO HI JANE HIGH DALLY I
DONT HI THERE ALSO HI GALGIANI.
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ. GROOVE HI
HERTZBERG. HILL HI WES SO HI
TADO HI JACKSON HI HI JONES HI
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL.
MONNING FIVE MORE LOCK HIGH
MORALE. NIELSEN HI HAND HI
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH. HI RUBIO
OUR EYES SKINNER. STERN I'M
BURKE FIVE Y. CALLES SKI HI
WIENER HI WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN HI
GALGIANI. GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HI
HI MITCHELL HIGH MORALE.
SKINNER STERN. ALL EYES THIRTY
FOUR IT KNOWS ZERO THAT
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIMED FILE
ITEM TO SENATOR WILL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TO SIT CONFIRMATION A
VERY BROAD TO THE AGRICULTURAL
LABOR RELATIONS BOARD PRIOR TO
HIS APPOINTMENT MR BROAD WAS
THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR THE
CALIFORNIA- CALIFORNIA
TEENAGERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL IN A MANAGING PARTNER
AT BROAD INVESTMENT L. L. P. HE
WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE IN FEBRUARY NINETY ON
IF A VOTE. THANKFULLY FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE DEBATE DISK ITEM ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE YOUR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARE TO LET UP HI ATKINS AYE
BATES. HI BILL. HI PORGES.
BRADFORD HI CAMBIADO HI CHANGE
HI DOLLY. DODD HI THERE ALSO HI
GALGIANI. GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
GROVE NO. HERTZBERG HI HILL HI
WES SO HI- TANTO HI JACKSON HI
JONES. LEYVA I HI MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL HI MONNING. FIVE MORE
LOOK HIGH MORALE. NIELSEN CAN
BY PORTANTINO HI ROSS HI RUBIO
I SKINNER. STERN I'M BURKE HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE WIENER HI
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BOARD YES. THE ALLEY.
GALGIANI GONZALEZ JONES. MORALE
NIELSEN SKINNER. STERN STERN
AYE AYES THIRTY KNOWS ONE THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. BACK
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR CHIANG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SOUTHLAND
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL FROM MY
DISTRICT IN ROWLAND HEIGHTS UP
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE GIVE THEM
A GREAT BIG SENATE WELCOME.
WELCOME TO SENATOR CHANGE YES.%
COLLEAGUES WE ARE NOW GOING TO
GO TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR RIPOFFS.
THING THAT A PRESIDENT- BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE WILL
MEET. AT TEN AM IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE ANYONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ROBB SENATOR PAN THANK YOU MATT
PRESIDENT- THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WILL BE MEETING AT TEN
AM IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
ANY FURTHER ANNOUNCEMENT CENTER
WERE CASKEY. IMPRESSIVE MAN
PRESENT SUBCOMMITTEE TO ON
RESOURCES ENVIRONMENT
PROTECTION WILL MEET IN ROOM
ONE ONE TWO- AT TEN O'CLOCK.
PENSION BELL. BUDGET SUBPHYLUM
CORRECTIONS IS GOING TO MEET IN
ROOM ONE ONE THREE AT TEN
O'CLOCK. SENATOR CAFIERO.
BUDGET SUBFORUM AGING AND
TWENTY. FORTY ARM RIGHT AFTER
SESSION IMMEDIATELY AFTER
SESSION AFTER SESSION VERY GOOD
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SEEING NONE WE
WILL RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE TIME TO
A JOURNEY IN MEMORY. SENATOR
HER. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I RISE TODAY TO JOIN I THE
MEMORY OF PORTABLE FIRE
DEPARTMENT CAPTAIN RAYMOND
FIGARO AND FIREFIGHTERS PATRICK
JONES SH EXCUSE ME CAUGHT I
KNOW THERE'S SOME NOISE IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER IF YOU
COULD PLEASE QUIETED DOWN SO
THAT WE CAN SHOW OUR RESPECT AT
THIS POINT IN OUR PROCEEDING
THANK YOU CENTER **** OF. WHO
DIED TRAGICALLY LAST MONTH
AFTER RESPONDING TO A FIRE AT A
LIBRARY IN THE CITY OF PORTABLE.
I'D LIKE TO START WITH THE
ADJOURNMENT OF CAPTAIN RAY
FORGET ALL. CAPTAIN RAY IF YOU
GO TO A BEGAN AS FIREFIGHTING
CAREER WITH LINDSAY CITY FIRE
DEPARTMENT. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN RAY WAS HIRED WITH PORTER
BILL CTY FIRE DEPARTMENT AS A
FIREFIGHTER. MAKING AN IMPACT
TO THE DEPARTMENT WITH HIS
PASSION AND DETERMINATION. AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN RAY WAS PROMOTED
TO THE RANK OF ENGINEER AFTER
MANY YEARS OF HARD WORK AND
TRAINING. AS AN ENGINEER RE
CONTINUE TO TRAIN AND WORK HARD
TO BECOME AN EXCEPTIONAL
ENGINEER. AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
RAY WAS PROMOTED TO CAPTAIN AND
WAS ASSIGNED TO STATION SEVENTY
ONE. HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS LOVE
OF THE JOB AND MENTORING HIS
CREW. OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS
RE WAS PART OF THE FIRE
INVESTIGATION UNIT. AND AS WITH
EVERY ASSIGNMENT RATE
APPROACHED INVESTIGATIONS WITH
PASSION. CAPTAIN FIGUEROA WAS
KNOWN FOR ST QUE S. A.
KNOWLEDGE SKILL AND ABILITY.
TWENTY WITH A LARGE PART OF
REYES DAY TO DAY JOB AND JOIN
THE PORTABLE FIRE TRAINING.
DEPARTMENT CHINA SKILLS
KNOWLEDGE AND LOVE OF THE JOB
WHEN HE CAME TO WORKERS
PRIORITIES SHOWED AND HE WAS
ALSO KNOWN FOR SAYING MY MAN.
THE MISSION BEND ME. RIGHT NOT
ONLY SERVE THE CITIZENS AND
COMMUNITY IN AND AROUND
PORTABLE HE OFTEN RESPONDED TO
LARGE WILDLAND FIRES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THROUGH HIS CAREER.
CAPTION FIGUEROA WAS THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OLD AND IS SURVIVED
BY HIS MOTHER ANNA. WE'RE
HONORED TO JOIN IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY. I'D ALSO LIKE TO TAKE
THE TIME TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY
OF FIREFIGHTER PATRICK JONES.
BYE BYE PATRICK JONES BEGAN HIS
CAREER IN THE FIRE SERVICE AS A
RESERVE FIREFIGHTER FOR THE
PORTABLE CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT.
DURING HIS TIME AS A RESERVE
FIREFIGHTER PATRICK STOOD OUT
WITH THE PASSION HE BROUGHT AND
THE MANY HOURS HE SPENT AT THE
FIRE STATION. PATRICK WAS KNOWN
FOR SPENDING ALMOST EVERY DAY
AT THE FIRE STATION HELPING THE
STATION PERSONNEL AND SERVING
THE COMMUNITY. AFTER WORKING AS
PATRICK WAS HIRED AS A FULL
TIME FIREFIGHTER AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. PATRICK WAS QUICK TO
MAKE FRIENDS WITH EVERYONE IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND ON FOR
ALWAYS HAVING A SMILE ON HIS
FACE. PATRICK WAS ALWAYS QUICK
TO HELP ANY OF HIS FELLOW
BROTHERS OR SISTERS ON OR OFF
DUTY HIS POSITIVE ATTITUDE WAS
INFECTIOUS AROUND THE FIRE
STATION. HIS DEDICATION
REIGNING WAS SEEN IN HIS WORK
ETHIC AS HE SPENT MANY EVENINGS
PRACTICING A BECOMING
PROFICIENT AS A FIREFIGHTER.
PATRICK HAD JUST BE. WORKING ON
TRAINING TO BECOME AN ACTING
ENGINEER. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING IN THE MEMORY OF
FIREFIGHTER PATRICK JONES
COLLEAGUES I'D ALSO LIKE TO
CLOSE BY MENTIONING THAT IN
HONOR OF CAPTAIN FIGARO AND
FIREFIGHTER JONES. THE CAPITOL
FLAGS WERE FOR FLOWN AT HALF
STAFF ON FEBRUARY NINETEENTH AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO HONOR THE
SACRIFICE. THE SERVICE AND THE
BRAVERY OF OUR FINEST
PFEIFFER'S IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR HER TADO ON THIS SHOULD
TURN IN MEMORY SENATOR GROWTH
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SPEECH ABOUT THE WE
BOWSHER AND SURROUND THE AREA
FRESNO IN AND THEN CAPTAIN
FIGARO WAS RESIDENT TO BE.
FILLED IN TWENTY HEARD DURING
THE MEMBER OF THESE AMAZING IN
THE- THESE BRAVE WORKING HERE.
CLOSELY GAVE THEIR LIFE ON
FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH AND JUST
THIS LAST MONTH IN THE LINE OF
DUTY. AFTER REMAIN FIGUEROA.
FIRE PATRICK JONES WERE THE
FIRST THE CREW. FIRST OF THE
CREEK ARRIVE THE SCENE AT THE
FIRE OF THE LIBRARY AND A RUN
ENGINE SEVENTY ONE. THREE
FIREFIGHTERS RESPONDED TO THE
ARSON FIRE ON THAT ENGINE IN
ONLY TWO. LEFT ALIVE OUR TO
NEARLY ONE SURVIVED. CAPTAIN
RAYMOND FIGUEROA A PROUD
RESIDENT BAKERSFIELD WAS JUST
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD. RAYMOND
WAS BORN AND RAISED IN DELANO
CALIFORNIA AND LIKE MANY OTHERS
HE GRAN HE BEGAN HIS CAREER IN
PUBLIC SERVICE. VOLUNTEER THE
LOCAL PART OF MEANT. IS OUT
SEVEN HE JOINED THE HERBAL CITY
FIRE DEPARTMENT AT TEAM KHLOE.
AND BECAUSE OF HIS. HARD
WORKING AND HE WAS PROMOTED TO
CAPTAIN AND ASSIGN THE STATION
SEVENTY ONE THE SAME STATION HE
DEDICATED WIFE TO AND THAT
FATEFUL CALL. RATE TRULY
ENJOYED HIS WORK AS HE WAS
FEARLESS- ALL SPIT IS TEAM
FIRST HE- THE SAME AS MY
COLLEAGUE AT. MY MAY THE
MISSION. A HE CERTAIN FOLLOW
THAT AUTO ON TUESDAY AFTER WHEN
HE THE MAY TO PER THE CITY OF
THAT COMMUNITY. AND THE LIFE OF
HIS OWN ABOVE HIS MEN. HIS MAN
HIS MISSION AND THEN HIMSELF.
OUTSIDE OF THE LEADERSHIP IN
HIS WORK- AND WORK HE WAS A
DEVOTED FATHER OF TWO AMAZING
CHILDREN ANY A CARING BROTHER
AND UNCLE ANY ELECTED DO A LOT
ABOUT THEIR ACTIVITIES AS-
FOURTEEN EVENTS. IT WAS A-
BURNER ANYTHING TO LEAVE BEHIND
A LEGACY OF HARD WORK AND
DETERMINATION HE LEFT THAT
LEGACY BEHIND AND NOW THE WORLD
KNOWS HIM AS THE HERO THAT HIS
FAMILY ALWAYS KNEW WE WAS.
PATRICK LEE JONES. SO RECEIVED
A WAS ALL RECEIVED CLASS I'LL
COME ON THAT PARTICULAR FIVE.
AND HE WAS JUST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD HE WAS RAISED IN BY
SAGA PATRICK ATTENDED THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO WORK
TOWARDS HIS DREAM OF BECOMING A
FULL TIME FIREFIGHTER. HE WAS
DETERMINED HE WAS ELEVEN AND HE
ALWAYS SUPPORTED HIS BROTHER'S
IN IN IN HIS WORK LIFE. IT IS
TO BE DEDICATED FIREFIGHTER
PATRICK WAS A DEDICATED SON A
PROTECTIVE LITTLE BROTHER A
LOVING FIANCE AND A LOYAL
FRIEND. TRICKS FOR FAMILY WAS
AND- HE- I'M HIS FAMILY DINNER
SPENT THE BIGGEST LEVEL LIFE
WAS MOM'S CORE SO HIS FOR SAID.
PATRICK'S VIBRANT PERSONALITY
AND INFECTIOUS SMILE EMBODY THE
SPIRIT OF A TRUE PUBLIC
SERVICE- WE ARE FOREVER IN THE
DEBT THESE BRAVE HEROES AND OUR
PRAYERS GO OUT TO THE FAMILY.
FRIENDS IN THE COMMUNITY. THEIR
LIVES OF OUR CELEBRATED JUST
LAST WEEK. WHERE SEE COMMUNITY%
AND YOU FORMS- FROM
FIREFIGHTERS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AT EL OVER THIS. TO HONOR THE
HEROES AND THAT WERE LOST SO MY
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS GO OUT TO
THE FAMILIES AND I ASK YOU TO
INTERN IN THE MEMORIES OF BOTH
THESE- AMAZING INDIVIDUALS. WHO
DIED IN THE LINE OF DUTY ON
TUESDAY FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW THANK
YOU CENTER HER TADO IF YOU
WOULD MAKE SURE THEIR NAMES ARE
BROUGHT FORWARD SO WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED THEM AND
PLEASE EXTEND THE CONDOLENCES
OF THIS BODY. TO THEIR FAMILIES
THESE WERE HEROES WHOSE LIVES
WERE CUT SHORT. FAR TOO SOON.
SENATE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT WE JOURNAL
THE MEMORY OF PRIVATE ADRIAN
ESTRADA AMAZING YOUNG MAN WHO
WAS A BRAND NEW SOLDIER AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
PRIVATE STRIDE WAS BORN IN
SANTA ANA ON AUGUST NINE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE THROUGHOUT
HIS LIFEADRIAN WAS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF HIS LOCAL CHURCH HE
SHOWED HIS FAITH IN MANY WAYS
HE WAS A ALTAR BOY WHO. REPORT
BUT HE DID NOT ASSIST FROM. SIX
IT INTO BEING A TO BOISE WAS A
TWO TO ME WHO SHE HIS GIVE THIS
CAN THROUGH G. THE CHURCH CHOIR
LOCAL BAND HE WAS A FANTASTIC
ATHLETE EXCELLED AT FOOTBALL
DURING HIS TIME AT SEARS FROM
HIGH SCHOOL HIS LOVE THROUGHOUT
THE COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY AT
HIS PARISH COURSE WHERE
KINDNESS AND CHARISMA WERE
EVIDENT TO ALL WHO ENCOUNTERED
HIM UPON GRADUATING FROM
SPEAKERS HI ADRIENNE TO TEN YOU
HIS FIRST TO OUR COMMUNITY A
NATION BY JOINING THE ARMY.
LIFE WAS GOOD SHORT. VERY
RECENTLY. UNFORTUNATELY BY A-
REPORTEDLY DRUNK DRIVER ON HIS
WAY HOME FROM A WASHINGTON
STATE WHILE ON ONE OF HIS FIRST
LEAVES- HE'LL BE REMEMBERED
DEARLY BY ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND IT. COME RATHER
AND SISTERS PROVIDED BY HIS
FAMILY HIS SIBLINGS FRANCISCO
SANDRA ANDREW AND COURSES
PARENTS EVA AND FRANCISCO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE WE JOURNAL
HIS MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG AND AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD BRING HIS NAME FOR SO WE
CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM
AND EXTEND CONDOLENCES TO. HIS
FAMILY. SENATOR PAM. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS- TODAY I
RISE TO TURN MEMORY OF L. FRANK
BILL TEENY JUNIOR WHO PASSED
AWAY ON EVERY TWENTY EIGHT AND
TWENTY TWENTY. FRANK WAS BORN
ON JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE IN
SACRAMENTO HERE SACRAMENTO AND
SPENT HIS ADULT YEARS LIVING IN
OAK GROVE IN WILTON CALIFORNIA.
THANK GREW UP IN SACRAMENTO
TENDING SAINT ROBERT'S
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL GRADUATING
FROM CHRISTIAN BROTHERS HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE.
HE AND HIS FATHER LEO HELLO TO
NY OWNED WELL LIKE A COMPANY OF
SACRAMENTO WHICH FRANK CONTINUE
TO RUN UNTIL EARLY TWENTY
NINETEEN. USE OF WROTE HE WAS
WELL RESPECTED THE CONSTRUCTION
IS FREE FOR THE WAY HE
GENUINELY CARED ABOUT HIS TEAM
AT ROYAL LECTURE COMPANY HIS
REPUTATION AS AN INDUSTRY
LEADER PROFESSIONAL. PRIMARY
WORK WITH THE WESTERN COUNTRY.
WESTERN CONTRACT THE SAYS IN AN
EXPANSION. ELECTRICAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. IN
ADDITION TO HIS WORK AT ROYAL
FRANK SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
REGENTS AND BOARD OF TRUSTEES
OF CHRISTIAN BROTHERS HIGH
SCHOOL. WHICH HE AND HIS WIFE
CARRIE CONTINUE TO GENEROUSLY
SUPPORT OVER THE YEARS. FRANK
ALSO SERVED AS A BOARD MEMBER
OF THE SECOND A BUILDERS
EXCHANGE THE BANK OF SACRAMENTO
TESCO CONTROLS INCORPORATED AND
W. CA. HE IS A MEMBER OF THE
ROUND TABLE ADVISORY GROUP OF
CLOSE FRIENDS BUSINESSMEN KNOWN
AS THE RACKS GROUP. FRANK LOVED
VOTING WITH KERRY ENTERTAINING
FRIENDS AND FAMILY ENJOYING
GOOD GREAT FOOD FINE WINE AND
TRAVELING ESPECIALLY TO VISIT
HIS FAMILY IN ITALY AND SUNDAY
FAMILY DINNERS. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE KERRY IN HIS THREE
CHILDREN TINA CAMPBELL CARLA
ALBRIGHT AND THE ABILITY IN THE
THIRD. AND THE SIX
GRANDCHILDREN. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A JOURNEY TODAY'S SESSION IN
THE MEMORY OF FRANK THE LITANY
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER PAN
AND AGAIN PLEASE BRING THE NAY
THEIR NAME HIS NAME FORWARD.
AND PLEASE EXTEND TO THE WHOLE
VILLAGE TO THE TEENY FAMILY OUR
CONDOLENCES. SENATOR MORLOCK
FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR. POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO WELCOME.
THE FOURTH GRADE CLASS FROM
SAINT JOHNS LUTHERAN SCHOOL
THAT JUST FLEW END AND CAME TO
VISIT US JUST IN THE NICK OF
TIME. IF WE COULD GIVE THEM A
WARM WELCOME. WELCOME TO
SENATOR MORE LAX YES COLLEAGUES.
WELCOME TO THE STATE CAPITOL.
AND WITH THAT MACHINE NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS THE
FLOOR IS CLEAR THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES ENJOY YOUR
WEEKEND WELL AREN'T WELL
DESERVED I WILL SEE YOU ON
MONDAY MARCH NINTH TWENTY
TWENTY AT TWO PM. THANK YOU THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO
PM.